noël aura charmé fait danser toute une
génération
sa carrière débute à la fin de son
adolescence
lorsqu'il remporte un concours
d'imitation dans les années 50 il fait
ses premières armes sur les planches du
cabaret et enregistre ses premières
chansons
rapidement paolo noël gagne le coeur du
public et anime des émissions de radio
et de télévision dont toast et café avec
dominique michel
travailler avec lui
plusieurs fois toujours été agréables
bongo
il y avait ceux qui avaient
un garçon qui se défendent et bien
finalement dans les big
le crooner connaît un grand succès grâce
aux reprises de chansons comme katrina
ou encore j'avais 20 ans j'en aurai
les yeux d'une femme
passionné de voyages et de navigation ce
sera le fil conducteur de bien des
chansons
son encre c'est sa femme diane bolduc à
ses côtés depuis plus de 50 ans espiègle
et farceur le chanteur a toujours une
anecdote à raconter
quant à elle s'illustre aussi comme
acteur dans l'attendu potential sont le
voit en
1999 dans la télésérie omerta évidemment
il y avait demandé je voulais participe
à la syrie si tu es intéressé par un
rôle vous êtes très longtemps qu'il y
avait partout et devant les caméras
évidemment il a accepté la proposition
des à partir de ce moment là bas ça a
été
ça a été le grand bonhomme les fous
rires sur le plateau au grand écran il
joue dans quelques films dont dix
mortels les doigts croches écoute au
rouge
[Musique]
2015 après une carrière de plus de 65
ans paolo noël tire sa révérence
[Musique]
c'est mélissa françois radio canada mon
frère
man
[Musique]
m
tu m'as vu
[Musique]